بينما تتواصل الحرب سيال بين روسيا
واوكرانيا تلوح كييف مجددا بالصيغه التي
طرحها الرئيس
فلوسكي للسلام مع روسيا رئيس مكتب
زيلينسكي وصفت تلك الصيغه بانها الطريقه
الوحيده لانهاء الحرب وان كيف تعمل مع
شركائها لتطوير فهم موحد لها
كان زيلنسكي قد طرحت تلك الصيغه وتتالف من
عشره بنود في قمه مجموعه العشرين
باندونيسيا منتصف نوفمبر الماضي ويروج لها
منذ اذن اقليميا ودوليا شملت الصيغه عده
نقاط بينها وقف العدائيات وانسحاب القوات
الروسيه واستعاده سياده ووحده اراضي
اوكرانيا دون شروط واطلاق سراح السجنائها
وتامين السلامه النوويه بجانب نقاط اخرى
تتعلق بالغذاء والبيئه
رفضت روسيا الصيغه بشده واعتبرها وزير
الخارجي سيرجي لافروف غير مقبوله وان
موسكو لن تتحدث مع اي طرف على اساسها ووصف
فكره اخراج روسيا من شرق اوكرانيا والقرن
بانها مجرد وهم واخيرا قال الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين خلال القمه الافريقيه
الروسيه في سام بطرسبرغ وهو يعلق على
المبادره الافريقيه لانهاء النزاع مع
اوكرانيا ان بلاده مستعده دائما للتفاوض
لكن كيف هي من ترفض في هذه الاثناء تستعر
الحرب على صعد مختلفه والتطور اللافت
الراهن وتجدد استهداف المدن من قبل
الجانبين
تقول اوكرانيا اين القوات الروسيه قصفت
مدينه دونيبرو بصواريخ اسكندر وسقط عدد من
الجرحى وتضررت بعض المباني ومنشات البنيه
التحتيه كما تعرضت مقاطعه روستوف الروسيه
الحدوديه لقصف صاروخي اوكراني واعترفت
روسيا باصابه 15 شخصا جراء انفجار بمقهى
في مدينه تاغان روك بالمقاطعه واعلنت
موسكو احباط محاولتين للقوات الاوكرانيه
للتقدم باتجاه منطقه سباتوف الجنوبيه وست
محاولات لاستعاده المناطق التي خسرتها
باتجاه اليمن
وعلى وقع الامور المشتعله تفقد الرئيس
زيلينسكي مواقع القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه
في خط الجبهه القريب من بخفوت بمقاطعه
شرقي البلاد كانت القوات الروسيه قد سيطرت
على بخ مود قبل اشهر ومنذ اذن تسعى الى
استردادها مع غيرها وتقول الروسيه ان
هجمات القوات الاوكرانيه باءت بالفشل